so you run a nursing home you know the
place your kids are going to send you
when you get to Old and senile now on
the surface this might sound like a
really Bland boring business like it's
really creepy in here what does that
very bad smell why would anyone want to
run a nursing home but under the surface
it is actually a gold mine because think
about it in every other business your
customers can complain if you abuse them
they can go to the police they can sue
you they can report you to the FTC but
nursing homes your customers are the
elderly and you have full control over
them lots shady goes down in
nursing homes Frank okay these places
are like prisons you help or don't help
them get out of bed if they pee
themselves you get to choose whether or
not to change their soiled clothes you
get the feet of prescription drugs you
get to control their access to the
outside world which means you can do
whatever you want to them and they won't
be able to tell us Soul about it which
has led to some pretty dark things
happening inside nursing homes
unexplained bruises open wounds and
other injuries all over the bodies of
nursing home customers customers being
left alone to sit in solar clothes for
hours customers spending all day crying
out for help from their beds only for
their pleas to go unanswered and when
some customers try to fight back you can
simply tie them to their wheelchairs
when that doesn't work you can just drug
them with super strong medications that
knock them out cold these are just some
of the things that have happened in one
nursing home in New York but the thing
is stuff like this is happening in
nursing homes All Over America Alden is
headquartered here in the city they
operate dozens of facilities but six are
named in this lawsuit nobody there to
help her she died alone struggling
horrific bed sores devastating and often
fatal flaws why because money think
about it most of these old people are on
Medicare and Medicaid they're barely
surviving off of money from the
governments they don't have any extra
money to afford better living conditions
which means they can't afford to leave
ah yes they have no choice but to pay
for your nursing home no one else is
gonna take them and no one is gonna hear
their cries stay dangerous subscribe for
more and this is the evil industry of
nursing homes
[Music]
oh
to make these videos I have to be
constantly reading books but the problem
is books take a lot of time to read and
not all books are created equal the way
I think about it is that 20 of the books
out there will give you 80 of the
results so your job is to shift through
as many books as possible to get to that
20 take this book for example the
Bitcoin standard I want to read this For
an upcoming video but it's 18 and 300
pages so instead of reading it right
away I first went through a summary of
the book on an app called short form I
got to confirm that yes this book is for
me and then I invested time into reading
it and it was all thanks to short form
short form offers the best book
summaries out there on over a thousand
non-fiction books I've used the other
book summary apps out there in the past
but the problem is they're usually two
surface level short form on the other
hand is way more comprehensive they're
so comprehensive that chances are the
key insights you get from reading the
actual book you will find on short form
it's more of a book guide than a book
summary so I highly recommend giving
short form a try and if you use my link
below right now shortfrom.com jaketran
you'll get 50 off the annual
subscription which is over 3 month free
that means for the price of one book a
month you'll get access to thousands of
short from book guides pause the video
and go to shortform.com with the link
below now thanks to shortfront for
sponsoring this video
in the 1700s when Europeans first
colonized North America they brought a
lot of things with them disease weapons
war and a thing called arms houses see
the thing is we've been trying to figure
out what to do with old people for
centuries and all of his houses were the
solution to that pesky problem back in
the day they were institutions run by
government organizations to house anyone
who couldn't be left alone or taken care
of by their friends or family but alms
houses weren't just for the elderly
anyone whose Society didn't want to deal
with could be dumpler orphans people
with disabilities the homeless drug
addicts and residents were provided with
a bed and meals but the conditions at
alms houses were depressing at best even
though alms houses were the norm for
over a hundred years over time people
started thinking that maybe this wasn't
the best place to send my parents or
grandparents sure it was fun to throw
addicts and homeless people in there to
forget they existed but the elderly were
different they were more worthy of care
so that's when a new type of institution
hit the scene old age homes
old age homes were established by
different religious and ethnic
organizations to take care of their
people in their final years there were
German houses Christian houses and even
hosts were just widows and single women
these places were Leaps and Bounds more
comfortable than alms houses but were
one major difference old age homes
charged a fee and for a while it seemed
like this new system was working out but
then America got hit with the Great
Depression all of a sudden people
couldn't afford to pay for old age homes
anymore so they started flooding back
into alms houses there weren't enough
best to keep up the conditions in alms
houses were getting worse than ever
before and everyone was freaking out
there had to be a better way Americans
pleaded and legislators agreed so they
came up with the perfect solution just
had the government throw small amounts
of money to old people that way they
would be able to pay for things like old
age homes enter Medicare and Medicaid
all of a sudden the entire demographic
of old people who were once broke were
now worth billions of dollars billions
of dollars that was guaranteed by the
federal governments every old person had
a dollar sign over their heads now a new
market was made and as an aspiring
entrepreneur if you wanted a cut of
these billions all you had to do was
open up shop
[Music]
thank you
Medicare and Medicaid was a gold mine
for nursing home owners it gave them the
incentive to build more and more nursing
homes to take in as many residents as
possible because each one was another
guaranteed paycheck from Big Daddy
governments but in 1970s there were more
nursing homes in the US than ever before
and their revenues their revenues had
risen by two thousand percent two
thousand percent so the only next
logical stuff for these nursing home
entrepreneurs to create nursing home
conglomerates why own one nursing home
when you could own two three four a
hundred cash flowing assets remember the
Medicaid money is there you just have to
suck up as much of it as possible
suddenly the nursing home wasn't Run by
One family or a religious organization
anymore it was operated by a
multi-billion dollar company whose
owners never stepped foot into the
hundreds of nursing homes they owned not
only did only hundreds of nursing homes
make them a lot of money but it also
made it way more difficult for the
government to oversee what was happening
inside these institutions and as the
profits and the quantity T of nursing
home skyrocketed the quality well it
suffered
foreign
Americans are living in nursing homes
right now as we speak and two-thirds of
those residents are paying for it with
Medicaid that sounds great right these
elderly people don't have enough money
to pay for it so the government steps in
to help but there's one giant caveat to
the system people who are taking
advantage of Medicaid are too poor to go
anywhere else their only option is a
medicaid-funded nursing home nursing
home owners know they have nowhere else
to go to and if your customers can't
leave why waste the money on improving
their experience what is the biggest
expense of running a business labor
paying staff salaries and nursing homes
are no different nursing homes need
staff to be working at the facility
around the clock to care for the
residents with the average nursing home
worker making over 18 an hour that could
quickly turn into thousands of dollars
in expenses every day even if you're
employing only a small staff so the
solution is simple just never hire these
people in the first place
yeah
it's a huge
drive
[Music]
this is a person that worked there that
knew terrible things were going on and
wrote this email this shows that I'm not
the only person that this has happened
to
me because your children you're thinking
should I do that
yeah that's stressful
that's fine we're fine I don't want to
die
you want to employ as few people as
humanly possible so that you can pocket
millions and your customers can't
complain about it because they're too
old too poor too sick to do anything
about it that is why stuff like this
happens every day 84 year old
grandmother
struggles to breathe
at home her daughter Marie had been told
staff were checking her mom throughout
the night
[Music]
the breathing gets weaker
and then stops Mama's Gone
and I believe
in all heart that the cause of her death
was due to
lack of
experience
Staffing not
knowing what they're doing
training
not enough staff I have laid in my own
bowel movement
for hours don't ever put your loved one
in here I do not want to come back here
I don't care if I lose the toes I don't
want to come back I don't want to
remember the memories of all the stuff I
got here imagine if you will a child day
care center
in which a child is burned severely
[Music]
things of cases
get a lot of attention yeah there'd be
outrage there's outrage
and typically
places are shut down
and the individuals arrested
nursing home World exact same facts but
instead of a young child an older adult
that's a citation most nursing homes are
neglected at best and are worse well
it's just a little bit too graphic to
talk about on YouTube which is why you
should click that join button below for
our uncensored documentaries by the way
and when people demand an answer for
these abysmal conditions in your nursing
homes all you gotta do is Scream from
the top of your lungs we need more money
[Music]
nursing home owners have been singing
the same tune for decades we don't have
enough funding to do our job the reason
nursing homes are scary abusive places
is because the government isn't giving
us enough money even though nursing
homes get over 50 billion dollars every
year from Medicaid alone and if you look
at their financial records that story
might seem convincing at first glance a
nursing homes tax records typically show
that they're making very little profit
but the truth is that as a nursing home
entrepreneur you have perfected a system
of Creative Accounting that allows you
to hide millions in profits the nursing
home industry would want you to believe
that they need more money from the
federal government and the state
governments that's not true they are in
fact making sizable profits and they're
making conscious decisions to understand
to increase their profit you see most of
these huge conglomerates don't just own
nursing homes they own land buildings
medical supply companies and all types
of other contracted services so when the
nursing home pays rent by supplies or
hires workers to do maintenance it's all
going right back into the pockets of the
owners and so that 200 000 goes on to
their operating costs sheet yes but
that's actually money that they're just
paying to themselves the nursing homes
pay way over market prices for all the
stuff they then deduct it as an expense
showing less profit while the money just
moves right into their other pocket
did you see how they were using
um shell corporations to move money
around them as an ex-prosecutor I saw
that and immediately thought wow that's
very similar to how organized crime
launders money that way the less it
looks like they're making the more the
nursing home industry can beg and plead
for more money from taxpayers they have
a financial incentive to make the
facility look as
unprofitable as possible they were
claiming 4.4 million the total expenses
well 1.4 of those was paid to themselves
and this isn't just happening at a
couple of nursing homes this is how the
nursing home business is run it's the
business model and all of them are doing
it
and I thought at first oh it's just this
one facility or this one chain this is
ramp this is everywhere it's been
accepted as the norm should it be
absolutely not
it's December 2022 and Moshe count the
owner of Fulton Commons is about to face
a very rude awakening his innocent
little Nursing Home in Long Island has
just been indicted and the Attorney
General himself is coming after him why
because Moshe and his family have been
committing fraud with their nursing home
for more than three years making over 16
million dollars worth of
government-funded money disappear by
paying for 10 salaries to his eight
adult children each one was getting paid
almost half a million dollars in 2020
for doing nothing as one percent
stakeholders talk about a dream job but
while they were living the good life all
the terrifying things we talked about in
the beginning of this video was
happening to his 280 vulnerable senior
residents and now people are finally
getting fed up
[Music]
in New York the governor passed a
Statewide law requiring nursing home
facilities to have a minimum number of
Staff but let's be honest laws like this
rarely make a difference and they
usually end up backfiring or the
industry would just find ways around it
the only real practical solution is
learning how to make more money so you
don't have to let your parents suffer in
a place like this and if you're looking
to get into business there is a very
important lesson in all of this the
nursing home industry solved the biggest
expense in business labor by just not
hiring any labor unfortunately for every
other business out there you can't just
not hire labor so the biggest
corporations out there have figured out
an alternative modern day slaves labor
from poor countries that is so desperate
so cheap so plentiful that it's
basically slavery without the whips and
chains and if you look closely you'll
find that pretty much all of the fortune
5 Runner companies have figured out some
way to leverage modern day slaves
because when you run the numbers it's
just not possible for a Nike for example
to scale to the size if they may choose
with expensive Western labor over so if
you're looking to get into business this
is a secret that you're gonna have to
understand if you want to scale that
they're not going to teach you anywhere
else because you know talking about
modern day slaves isn't very politically
correct which is why I expose all of
this in financial slavery masterclass 20
plus lessons all narrated by me in the
same documentary style format you've
come to love because I believe that
education should be as entertaining as a
Netflix series and you can watch the
first lesson for free right now with the
link below there's a 14 day no questions
asked refund policy just email us and
you can also earn around a hundred
dollars for every person you refer to
this masterclass as well so scroll down
click the link below and watch the first
lesson for free right now
[Music]
thank you